[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have my hello thanks to having
bad guys I am I am I am back beam backs
makes sense beam back
mmm cuz he's being back he's been back
boo and this episode is sponsored by
Roman did you guys know that half of men
over age 40 experience erectile
dysfunction at some point in their life
and you know that about 75 percent of
those guys don't even seek medical
treatment for the issue that's crazy man
this is why Roman has made it easy to
chat with a doctor online with Roman you
can get medical care for IDI if
appropriate from the comfort and privacy
of your own home you can handle
everything online in a convenient
discreet manner getting started is
simple just go to get Roman comm / OTR
sensor off the record and complete an
online visit if your doctor decides that
treatment would be appropriate they can
prescribe genuine medication that can be
delivered and discreet packaging so your
nosy neighbors don't know what you're
getting right to your door with free
two-day shipping talk to the doctor
erectile dysfunction can be tough to
tackle but it's really important to get
checked out with Roman it's easy to
connect with a doctor that's right so
check the link in the description box
below for free online visit and free
2-day shipping and thank you to Roman
for sponsoring this video that's right
there's nothing shameful about erectile
dysfunction what's shameful is not
handling that stuff also on Roman doctor
will never ask you for dick pics just
yeah just a good heads-up yeah watch out
are you sure about that yeah you hope
that they would ask for it oh they need
I would hope so can you imagine if a
doctor asked you for a dick pic and you
started laughing at you I never see I've
never seen not at Roman they want to do
that though he's like oh I haven't seen
baby dicks in a long time is there like
a his Roman and Trojan is there like a
theme like on purpose or is that just a
coincidence I don't know it could be
your Allison you know like there's all
sexual stuff Greek
Oh could be could be maybe Creek Italian
don't know that is Italian Mediterranean
Greek yeah anyways had the Greeks were
obsessed with sexuality for sure I mean
look at all the statues and stuff and
stuff did you know they thought small
dicks were beautiful right that's why
the statues and they're so small what's
symmetrical its symmetric no they
thought it was uh it was beastly an
animal like to have a big dick which I
agree yeah me too big dicks are like you
know you're like you're like a bull or
you're like that oh yeah what other
animals yo Charlie got like a yeah well
maybe yeah but they're like little dicks
like this it's polite classy it's very
offensive you're polite which one of the
tips oh you know sometimes you know it
goes all the way you know just like it
goes either way you got one of those
they were like oh it's classy different
different moods that dick is classy dude
it's so classic what dude says jack of
all trades
what says v-neck today at any cost
oh wait what would say know what mood
says v-neck today at any cost
sexy oh yes sexy mike is urging plunging
Mike wakes up sexy dude probably got
sexy pajamas his pajamas are v-neck yeah
I guess I'd be surprised if this who
shows up at funerals sexy oh my god
baked like everything the last button is
always here so you see kind of Peck yeah
a little bit yeah Mike man it's like oh
yes funeral I get to wear a suit damn I
can't wait you can't wait for sexy might
show it here for the funeral yeah what
do you get be family and I bet it's
gonna be sexy probably do its
I got a hole up are you gonna be a fire
but like a fireman calendar fireman
lemon calendar I
be a calendar you could do it just be a
calendar I've never been a fireman for
Halloween I've never been a sexy thing
for Halloween really if you guys been a
sexy thing for Halloween
never had to do that
I was arrested oh dude all we did was
just where we went to like big five or
something got the big jerseys and then
we caught them up all like oh so you
made it sexy wasn't no I'm sure you can
find it on online sexy but ID a
regulation recipe people couldn't go oh
that's from the NFL or we're paying
attention to what we're saying for sure
nobody you want recognizable that's know
we're f yeah
which league is you do your effing um
the ones that wear wet black probably
the lingerie Super Bowl oh that one's
recognized yeah that was the last time I
was anything sexy girls can make
everything sexy for Halloween now you
could be a [ __ ] chip bag and all they
do is like they just put the wrapper on
their nipples or something yeah yeah it
was a sexy broccoli a couple years ago
which is pretty funny sexy bra she just
covered herself in green put a [ __ ] a
green afro on everybody red green hot
shorts oh I say like potty paint go yeah
go could ho everybody what were you
thinking I'll seem like the broccoli
like mascot and I'm like how how did she
manage your paper mache broccoli with
tits out or something's acting around
like what what yeah I get it
I've been a sexy pirate oh yeah pirate
tickets could be sexy yeah sure like I
was showing my belly and that was the
first time I ever did like that was like
the sexy yes if you do anything and show
Katie or ass it's sexy what is it about
Halloween that makes girls want to [ __ ]
it up a little bit if it's fantasy time
you can get away with being as like like
living in any fantasy you want to live
in but don't you think that girls are
already [ __ ] follow anything
oh girl you think I'm [ __ ] no oh so
then does that apply to all girls well
girls are pretty default [ __ ] is what
we're saying yep yeah yeah so I'm a
thief up [ __ ] yeah for sure yeah
absolutely I don't think so but I think
don't you guys wear something more
climate appropriate there's a range we
live in SoCal late October we saw you
forea and the girl dressed as Bob Ross
so that's not sexy at all
she wasn't sexy Bob Ross I was thinking
sexy Barbara sexy Bob Ron I'm sorry I'm
tell about the epidemic across the world
now even in East Coast like Pennsylvania
Virginia or it's [ __ ] snowing during
Halloween that's true bill sexing it up
yeah sexing it up there's a lot of space
to fight you just sexy
yeah there's a lot of sexy mind well why
are why are no default setting sexy but
not all dudes are exactly all chicks
want to sex it up even if they're not
six yes you're growing up in New York
yeah wasted owners have even when girls
are not sick you another apology video
so when you go to like clubs during
Halloween time right yeah there's
probably maybe I don't know maybe like
five out of ten girls should be wearing
the sexy side of clothes five out of ten
that should be when the other kind you
know hey all girls are sexy [ __ ] you
okay huh every girl is sexy doesn't
matter what you every girl is sexy Jean
right we think their whole body
yeah right I know beauty is in the eye
the beauty is in the eye of the beholder
you think this [ __ ] look at J do that
[Laughter]
what you mean listen you don't mansplain
we know this up right now I'm like
sitting here and I'm like Jo needs
backup cuz this is ridiculous
okay do you think she needs backup cause
she's a woman and stop it would be nice
if I could back her up let me rephrase I
think you shaking your head and it was
good and then I started and then I was
just shaking my head I'm like I'm too
[ __ ] sleepy for this right now this
is all I can do so you weren't even [ __ ]
in your head you were just trying to
stay awake no no no not even that I'm
just the girls can't even back each
other you're disappointed I mean
disappointed in all of you [ __ ]
why I didn't even say anything what do
you I was laughing at everybody okay
sexy is everything what I've been saying
there's some ugly ass girls out there by
paying attention I've been saying
everything I've been saying have been
questions I have not made a single
statement or opinions looking for
approval understand okay let me give
another hypothetical let's say a dude
wants to be the tall basketball player
character but it's Jason Chen exactly
he's five feet tall or maybe is 4/10
okay hmm
can you still be the tall basketball
player if you have to buy a Lakers
Jersey and triple x-- small bar they can
call guys for tall
all guys call bar we got objective all
girls are sexy all guys guys taxi and
tall in Japan
tall massive tall height those are
[ __ ] genetic know Paul is objective -
ha ha ha and well that's alive one is
Paulus [ __ ] to someone that's 4 3 yeah
and it depends on culture you're not
being culturally sensitive because in
Asia I'm a tall man tell a very short
person there used to be called midgets
but I call them very short people yeah
tell a very short person that a 5 foot 3
person is not tall they will do and it
depends on the [ __ ] era because you
know what back in 1920 yeah 5 6 was tall
okay you won it's a stupid question well
I would love a short person to do that
to be like Shaquille O'Neal and be like
what are you for our anyway I'm at all
I'm at all Paul Shaq
I'm possibly today and then Bart would
say I don't think you are that I would
say that the girls all guys are tall
that's what the girls would say well
what would you say right now what
what would you say right now oh I would
say I think you should subscribe tall is
subjective or if you disagree I don't
give a damn just go ahead and subscribe
I don't know which is the s because we
need to build that not the only one
anyway can I get to two million y'all
and something specials gonna happen on
Jay King news at 2 million we might
bring one of you on board I don't know
what say two million Oh everyone's not
ugly except for some people everyone
yeah everyone's good looking at artists
except for something you're kind of not
there yet oh no I bet it's not what I
heard I heard everyone is if you believe
you are yes then you watch yeah well I
don't believe it
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's okay yeah girls are very
interesting subscribe to a of them
saying we have yellow dumb [ __ ] like
some girls are sexy somewhere oh I wish
I had the yellow memo thank you jean
jacket memo but not the element yes look
what this is just turned into the same
[ __ ] yeah damn way to make it
interesting right you had your hair Mike
we get a clickable link to this podcast
please god damn we're just constants
just getting better by the day that's
taking news baby good thing this is for
you this is a free one did you we did
you move to LA Mike five years ago five
years ago
it's 25 years in a couple days actually
yeah yeah la ever sory yeah let me guess
you live in k-town no I live close
Hollywood could you try to be active in
k-town no I didn't because almost every
person I know that moves here for film
or expensive the first two or three
years everyone always lives in k-town or
the valley best bang for the buck and
access the key times are all the funds
that happens though Korean barbecue we
call Korean BBQ and all the Asian clubs
I don't know if you like those
well I've so many more Asian friends in
our labors in New York and like they all
hang out in the Koreatown clubs who did
you grow up with around New York Greeks
the Romans the Trojans okay actually
yeah a lot a lot of Greek a lot of
Jewish Italian Italian yeah so was it a
culture shopping at Han you're like whoa
nobody talks what do I do
that's how they talk in New York they
have an empire state mine over there
yeah yeah but no I mean the East Coast
Asian in the West collision is
definitely are a little different what's
the difference tell me no I'm very
curious because when I go there I'm like
oh very different I think I think
there's more Asian community here really
in terms of like Asian power like like
what did you say like we got each
other's backs
what about like flushing or like uh like
the big Chinatown cities I think
sometimes it's a little more maybe
there's a little more Asians in New York
who want to assimilate more but in LA
that I guess there's more ages in LA so
yeah 66 nolan's foreign assimilating
they're like [ __ ] you we're gonna keep
all our signage in Chinese doesn't
matter if you can't read exactly we're
gonna turn KFC at the [ __ ]
KF duck yes yeah peeking duck yeah no
yeah it's like like that you like do not
put your shoes on in my house versus in
New York like you can wear your shoes in
my house Oh Oh see it isn't so yeah yeah
it's crazy really
it's wild in New York I heard that
especially on the East Coast no matter
if you're Asian or not everyone takes
their shoes up in they go no when they
go inside their house because seasons
and stuff like when it's like snowy and
[ __ ] you take your shoes off oh yeah you
stick your snow boots on oh well yeah
I'm not rich you damn well better out
there what
there's no beauties in everything that's
gonna offer optional in my house mm-hmm
same I used to live in the East Coast
and we would take our snow boots off but
we would leave our shoes on wait so do
you wear shoes like inside you're so
good don't confuse I remember one you
wear shoes inside it will you wear
double shoes double shoes yeah
what's the in what's the inner shoes you
wear - you gotta wear two pairs of shoes
now when it snows really bad it's trip
emotion isn't it hey if it's losers
goodness is it like kind of those hairs
just the way she's Saturday maybe it's
not like he was wearing two pairs of
shoes I'm like that just makes it unless
you're wearing those old-school [ __ ]
you know those big big things where you
have to put your shoes yeah I always saw
those occasions from Alaska why are they
it's in the other office oh the real
trick is if you're gonna want three pair
of shoes you have to get one obviously
has to be the biggest and then the
smaller ones mom I'm like imagine like
the Iron Man Hulkbuster armor like you
already have the Iron Man armor but then
you have like the armor on top of the
armor so unnecessary but you're really
thankful for it when it comes in handy
mm-hmm bless you friend they're taking
that [ __ ] good for you man hey the
Hulkbuster thing is pretty ridiculous
the what Buster the Hulkbuster thing you
wouldn't know this young accountant
you're not a nerd but we're all nerds I
guess Queens is there is Queens like
what kind of peoples are there's a mixed
or you guys very diverse I think it's
one of the most diverse places in the oh
man I don't know [ __ ] is more yeah like
I'll be assimilated because like la is
very diverse
but segregated yeah is it like it's
mixed it's very much like San Francisco
kind of except more let less a little
more less clean the San Francisco oh if
it's between Wow
I just know all these from like movies
and like music like Brooklyn
we're Brooklyn right I don't even know
where is where like no guys I'm from
Long Island like I've been in New York a
half full at times and [ __ ] but I'm just
never I don't know where the [ __ ] I am
they have little arms in Long Island
Island the Jersey City and hi seriously
I'm pretty good at like [ __ ] place
like when I get to places I memorize the
location pretty [ __ ] well New York
has been the place where I just don't
know where the [ __ ] I am everything it's
a grid that's the only place actually
[ __ ] I know where I am at least so
goddamn spread out that's why I like you
said be so different because everyone's
so [ __ ] spread out it takes forever
to get anywhere like in New York
everyone's on top of each other in the
same grid area maybe I'm not yes five by
point land of the five down like from
gangs in New York five points is within
Manhattan but despite boroughs sorrows
what the [ __ ] is a borough I know right
actually New York self isn't burrows
right
dang yeah yeah Queens the Queens
Manhattan Brooklyn Bronx and Staten
Island what about people say butts die
what's that that's a part of Brooklyn oh
yeah
but the butts yeah it's really diverse
like the food there the Asian food there
specifically to is like really good like
I went to Asia for the first time
Singapore yeah and then my friend was
like almost take you to the best
Singapore noodles and you're like we had
this way oh yeah it's pretty good I'm
spoiled I'm with you I would just
had the noodle wasn't that good I've had
better news middles in my lane yeah yeah
la New York like that all the all the
Asian food actually a firm was moving
away from LA and we had he's like she
was like I need to have KBB Q now as my
going away it's better than Korea and I
was like wait why she's like cuz is that
there's no KBB Q when I'm moving back
home and I'm like I'm so spoiled in New
York and LA just 20 minute drive do big
dollars in Denmark what's in there we
eat if we're McDonald's but tastes
cleaner oh oh oh just clean the counts
you know Queen er the McDonald's in
Beijing is boba what that's crazy
yeah
[Music]
[Music]